no bug left behind is the motto of this
ant species found in the southern
regions of Africa when the ants hunt
termites a risky prey the colony sticks
together marching into battle and column
and making sure even injured amps make
it back large amps called majors break
up the soil around termite nest during a
raid while smaller minor ants slip
through the cracks to extract their meal
soldier termites fight back and ants
lose limbs and antenna in the scuffle
after the fight
the ants line up to go home carrying
termite carcasses along for a post
battle feast when predators like spiders
see injured and struggling home they
know they're in for an easy snack so
major stick around after the fight
tracking the son of a pheromone that
signals injury when an injured ant is
found the major grabs the fallen soldier
in its mandibles and carries it home to
recover safely in the nest see what
became of those injured amps researchers
created laboratory nests and hunting
grounds and mark the injured with tape
95% of those hurt ants marched alongside
their brethren on future rates the
number of ants rescued each day is about
the same as daily ant first meaning
rescues help the colony stay strong and
prepared to fight another day
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you